one of the most recent sketches aired by
Saturday Night Live has lots of Comedy
fans upset the premise of the sketch in
question was supposed to be a fake
commercial for a new line of miniature
airport luggage with the punch line
being a bunch of different small items
that could fit inside these miniature
bags and that's it perfect for carrying
one airpod and one Al and half smoked
cigarette and a third now this may look
like a typical run-of-the-mill El sketch
to most but fans of New York comedian
Giannis papis were quick to recognize
exactly where they've seen this joke
before and I want to go see the latest
tylie Perry and then I would like to go
to BBQ that's it clothes for a worm and
that's it that's it and that's that's
and that's that's it and that's it
that's it and that's
Allin I mean that's it you stole it